what does this mean to you guys to be
officially in the play and bracket and
the playoff bracket and to do it with
this kind of win
tonight over a team that has really been
such a huge rival for you
over the second half of your career well
i mean going into the postseason i think
it's two of the hottest teams i think we
were winner of five they were winner of
uh seven or eight or whatever the case
may be
so both teams playing at a high level
and uh we knew that they're going to
come onto our floor and give everything
that they had
um you know they hit us in the mouth in
the first half and we just had to
respond and we did that on a defensive
end
and uh got some great contributions from
guys off the bench um and we all you
know chipped in for this win
we got to talk about that shot you hit
with about a minute left
the three you didn't even look in rhythm
there what were you thinking as the ball
left your hands
um you know just um and i put a lot of
work in my game
you know um you know after you know
drake my
finger to the eye i was literally seeing
three uh three rims out there
um so i just shot at the middle one and
uh and i was able to uh
the grace of the man above i was able to
knock it down when in doubt
go for the middle brim what did it feel
like when you were down there on the
floor when you took that hard fall were
you worried that you wouldn't be able to
continue in the game or have more
problems um
you know i've been there before um you
know i've been poked an eye before you
know on a rim collision like that so
just try to keep my composure you know
it's gonna be pretty sore tonight i know
that for sure
but we have a few days until we until we
know uh when we'll go to phoenix but
it's a big time win for us and i
definitely wasn't leaving the floor no
matter if i had to
you know put a pirate uh patch in my
eyes so
i love this team and i love to compete
one big rivalry down
with this win tonight but you've got
another one to go with an old friend in
chris paul you mentioned going to
phoenix and facing the suns what do you
think that matchup is going to be like
um you know they've played uh extremely
well all year and they deserve to uh
you know host uh you know home court in
the first round
and uh cp uh you know played at the mvp
uh caliber year all year um book you
know aiden has grown all year
and uh they've given those guys a
supporting cast around them so
you know we know what we're going to get
out of cp we know how good
uh you know how great cp is how great
book is
uh up-and-coming surgeons from you know
from aiden
um you know but it's the other guys as
well that we got to make sure we key in
on because they've been playing
extremely well all year and that's why
they've been the second best team in the
world
and now we're going to live to lebron
james as he addresses the media
you know i've been i mean i practice
enough i work on
you know my game and uh i was able to uh
get a man above and
do a lot of practice so i was able to
drain it
we saw the respected exchange between
unad and stephen draymond after the game
what did it take in that second half
what was the adjustment for you guys to
match up what they had been putting out
to create that lead
we just had to bring the fight to the
fight you know they uh
you know they was ready to fight and we
tried to you know eat into the game a
little bit
you know it's been a while since we've
been in postseason it's been a while
since we had one of those type of
you know um you know those energy
um effort uh every possession count
games and
uh you know and i feel like they've been
playing you know kind of play off
basketball for quite a while so
we had to catch up to that but once we
made that adjustment in the second half
we was able to take the fight to them
and make a game out of it
right you uh weren't a fan of the
playing tournament uh we're pretty clear
about that
but you know what you know the history
of the nba and what the spectacle of
drawing fancy nba means what do you
think about it after tonight's
game um when i was asked about i told
you how i felt
um you guys asked me a few days ago um
how i felt
and i said i'm ready to go i said later
you know you know where the chips lay
where they met
you know and so you know i showed up and
we showed up and we was ready to play
so lebron where are you at
physically not just i mean what all
happened on that play where draymond
fouled you
you're down for a while was it was it
only the eye were you hurting in a few
spots how did you come out of the game
in regards to that play and then also
with your ankle uh i'm good
um i told you guys i was good i'm good
it's most minutes i've played in a long
time and i didn't feel anything on that
play
um you know draymond uh is either finger
or thumb or whatever
uh went directly into into my eye and um
you know that's why i was down so i was
just you know making sure i was okay
uh making sure i wasn't bleeding make
sure i could see a little bit at least
so i could finish the game
can you kind of take us through sort of
the
mood at halftime of this game um and
what changed most do you think for you
guys early in the third
um you know doesn't smooth pretty much
got on our ass at halftime
um smoove is uh keith morris if you
don't know what smoove is but
uh they got on us and showed us that you
know you know we gotta pick it up
pick this [ __ ] up um they brought the
fight to our building and we got to
bring it right back and
you know um guys like that you know
speaking listen we took it to heart we
didn't take it personal
uh we just took it with us and uh we
improved our effort in the second half
i'm glad i know you're obviously going
to do a lot of research on phoenix
coming up but
what does it mean up at the top to just
be in a series with chris
and go against him in the playoffs for
the first time in your careers
um it's a beautiful thing i mean our
journeys
we've been playing this game at such a
high level for a long time and
i've always rooted um for him for d-wave
for mello to succeed and
got an opportunity to play against mello
in the playoffs a few times um
you know i never got the opportunity to
play against d-wade in the postseason
but we played
you know also has a great four-year run
in miami and um
you know so it's gonna be pretty cool
just to be on the same floor and
competing one of the most fierce
competitors
that this game has had over his career
and um look forward to the matchup
what's up brian what's going on hey you
guys got a lot of contributions tonight
but as caruso always seems to step into
big games of both you guys what is this
about him that makes him be able to do
that
um his attention to detail
um you know just smart
smart very very smart know what we want
to do uh
you know always in the right place at
the right time and
you know he just uh just makes plays you
know makes plays some of them show up in
the box for some of them then
don't but tonight they definitely showed
up in the box boy i mean he pretty much
carried us in the first half offensively
and uh we just had to match him on the
second half
last question mark medina
hey lebron what jumped out to you this
season how you guys have handled all the
different forms of adversity and also
tonight and what do you think that means
moving forward in the playoffs
only time will tell but you know it was
good to uh
you know get that first punch they say
everybody you know
say mike tyson always said everybody got
a plan um
until you get in the ring you get you
get punched you know
so uh we did that and it felt good um
it felt great to settle us uh wasn't
comfortable but it settled us and uh was
able to bring the fight to them so
you know we're looking forward to you
know what's gonna be in store
you know for the for the post season so
and uh we got one post season game under
our belt we look forward to the next